in case you didn't know at least one of
the endings of eldon ring the one i
defended in my which ending his best
video the age of the stars has some
serious mistranslations which might
affect its meaning and lore implications
an article released two weeks ago from
frontline jp that claimed the dialogue
spoken by ronnie in the ending along
with her final voice lines at her rise
were mistranslations there were a few
videos released reporting on the article
and i've gotten an unending stream of
comments just letting me know that
actually the ending was mistranslated
whenever it comes up in one of my videos
so in this video i want to talk about
the mistranslations and what they mean
for the lore and our understanding of
the ending
first i haven't discussed the
mistranslations yet because i was
working on other videos and because i
wanted to verify the potential
mistranslations before i mindlessly
reported on them fortunately i have two
genuine native japanese speaking friends
who are nice enough to take some time to
review the article and the
mistranslation claims they have both
confirmed that the article is pretty
much correct and the english text and
voice lines are basically
mistranslations
the main thrust of difference between
the english and the original japanese is
that the english is both more obscure
and contorts a lot of the japanese
meaning i already explained the english
in my previous video so i'll just
summarize the japanese here
unlike the english the japanese ending
dialogue says that the chill night is
not beginning but will be kept far away
and the journey of loneliness on the
dark path is a personal one for ronnie
and maybe us as the tarnished as well to
go on to keep the knight far away not
one that everyone will be going on the
dialogue in ronnie's room explains this
more the order is what ronnie wants to
keep far away she may think that it is
impossible to destroy the order without
also destroying lives and souls this is
a thought that could be supported by
what i talked about in the outer gods
video that the greater will was
responsible for creating individuals and
lives and souls its order cannot be
destroyed without also destroying its
effects individuals and lives and so
forth so the order may be needed but
ronnie thinks it would be better if it
were far away where people couldn't
touch or clearly see it maybe so that
they would not be directly influenced by
it
the english took ronnie's words about
not being able to touch or clearly see
it to be a lot stronger than they were
in the japanese where she is simply
suggesting that it might be better that
way and that she is talking about the
order not simply the senses themselves
the article concludes succinctly
summarizing the actual state of things
it says
ronnie believes that while the order may
have to exist as it is entwined with
life and souls it causes problems for
the people her solution is thus to take
it and leave keeping it far away where
people cannot see feel touch and believe
in it embarking on a journey into fear
doubt solitude and darkness to do so
so there we have the updated ending and
to be fair it seems pretty clear now we
might ask how should we view the ending
differently well i have two answers to
this first i don't think this really
changes much thematically from my
original interpretation sure there's a
change in that ronnie didn't destroy the
order but the idea of removing influence
from outside forces and letting people
live their own individual lives was the
central theme i took out of the ending
before and that is basically the
takeaway of the japanese lines as well
i know a good amount of people took the
ending in english to be pretty ominous
but this should probably put those fears
to rest
this really only strengthens my previous
case that the age of the stars ending is
the best one giving freedom and
individuality to people by taking an
actually meaningful action to change the
current status quo
obviously this is still my previous line
of argumentation so if you haven't seen
my which ending is best video that will
explain things in more detail even
though that's working off of
mistranslations but as i said doesn't
seem like the mistranslations change the
theme very much at least from what i
took from it before my second answer to
how this should impact our view of the
ending is basically i don't care the
version of the game that essentially
every english player plays is the one
with the mistranslations mistranslations
that got all the way from dialogue and
descriptions to the actual voice lines
of dialogue i remind you that the
english voice lines are the only voice
lines recorded for eldon ring there are
no original voice japanese lines the
dialogue is english only i mean yeah
it's cool to see what was actually
intended by fromsoft and it does seem to
be more straightforward and make easier
sense but also my experience with the
game is with the descriptions i read and
the dialogue i hear the tones and themes
still shone through the same at least
they did to me and that is really the
most important part it's also a part
that oftentimes does not really need
deep lore speculation to reach so yeah i
don't care that much about the
mistranslations it's cool to get the
original text but the game in english
has become a bit of its own beast and
players will treat it as such at least
until fromsoft decides to fix the
mistranslations which i'd say has about
a 0.1 percent chance of happening this
might be a very unusual case of death of
the author
for better or for worse the english game
stands on its own and i think that's at
least neutral since the themes read
similarly to me so really i don't think
it's something to sweat that much
yeah it might be mistranslated but the
story and its culmination still stand in
the same place in all their lore based
splendor and ronnie ii still remains
based
there are of course more questions about
the moon ronnie's connections and plenty
more lore of the lands between so if you
want to see here and explore more of
that you should subscribe as i'll be
making more excursions into the lore on
my channel i hope you enjoyed watching
and feel free to leave a comment about
your thoughts on the mistranslation and
what it means to you again thanks for
watching bye